employment ministers meeting in
Luxembourg took a new step in the fight
against Undeclared work in the EU they
agreed to set up a platform where member
states and other actors such as social
Partners can share information and
promote joint actions between National
enforcement authorities to curb the
shadow economy in the EU
you have a mandatory cooperation
in the platform on the part of the
member's state so that's a commitment on
the part of all member states and the
non-exhaustive list of initiatives
however member states would still be
right on their level of involvement in
the platform's activities
with the midterm review of the EU 2020
strategy underway EU employment Minister
started preparing their contribution to
the European Council which will tie all
threats together during its December
meeting ministers stressed that
employment and social objectives are a
very important part of the eu's
sustainable growth strategy they also
believe that social aspects need to be
better taken into account in the eu's
economic governance